when it comes to our pgs you can't get
any more classic than the Final Fantasy
series even if bravely default comes
pretty close now imagine the people
behind those two titles creating a game
together well it's totally happening mr.
Walker was founded by Final Fantasy
creator hironobu sakaguchi and they've
developed RPG staples like Blue Dragon
and lost odyssey now they're teaming up
with bravely default developers silicon
studio for something completely new the
project will reportedly mix missed
Walker's creativity with silicon studios
technical prowess so far the teams have
only teased a single image showing off a
knight and a dragon the image has
actually been around since 2009 and it
highly resembles artwork from missed
walkers tera battle perhaps this new
game is related missed walker and
silicon studio have said they'll have
more information at some point in the
future so for now we'll just have to sit
tight whatever it is you can expect
swords and magic and Dragons and
everything else you love about rpgs and
if you want to stay up to date on all
the RPGs on the horizon you're already
in the right place